gott das ist wirklich dass brokerhäuser
das bronze deathmatch niemals jemals war
ein deathmatch so brock wie dieses
servus skills und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video wir spielen heute
genau die ampel league natürlich ist ein
neuer tag neuer tag es nicht nur morgens
aufstehen in die schule gehen oder zur
arbeit gehen aber so macht essen trinken
sondern ein neuer tag heißt auch eine
neue jump it challenge und die heutige
stammt von free tv wie heißt die
challenge treiben du darfst von jeder
ändert und drei items rausnehmen und
immer wenn du einen check point erreicht
hast musst du ein item wegschmeißen die
beschlüsse der tom okay damit stimmten
dafür
es macht man natürlich war zack bumm und
wir fangen hier an welche drei teams
nehmen wir raus also wie gesagt drei
teams pro kiste wenn wir auch in dieser
wunderschönen gelb blöcke damit dem
peugeot tags drauf ist apple heißt dass
ein weiteres item wegschmeißen
so leute und ich muss euch kurz etwas
erzählen zwar war ich heute zum ersten
mal meinem ganzen leben bei einem
boxtraining kollegen herzlich damit
hinschmeißen weg den goldhelm will ich
sagen oder nähte gott gesagt die gothic
und die haben wir jetzt hier etwas
rausgenommen
ja wir haben okay das sind wir raus
genommen dürfen noch zwei rausnehmen und
wir nehmen die beiden raus und schauen
weiter bis zum nächsten checkpoint genau
was sollte jetzt hier mein kumpel hat
mich zum teil boxtraining mitgeschleppt
und es war erstmal höllisch anstrengend
okay das war's mir sowieso es weg hier
will keiner
aber was jetzt gold ich sag ich mal den
gold hinweg bogen und waffen will ich
unbedingt behalten so was nicht mehr
hier raus 1 23 alles klar da haben jetzt
gleich schön material wegschmeißen
können ja das training hat mich total
zerstört aber was das schlimmste ist für
mich als gamer ist das meine linke hand
nicht mehr funktioniert es ist kein
scheiß leute meine linke hand
funktioniert nicht mehr mein kleiner
finger der eigentlich dafür da ist um
auf den steuerung button auf meiner
tastatur zu drücken
da muss jetzt die ganz wegschmeißen
dahinten checkpoint welches weiter weg
goldbarren bekommt eh nicht zum gold
fotografen hier wieder drei rausnehmen
mein kleiner finger ist einfach total
reckt gold stufe braucht man nicht 123
und ich kann einfach gerade wirklich
meinen kleinen finger kaum benutzen und
das ist überzeugt ohne leiter gesprengt
wenn man dann die leute mal erreicht
weil man dann einfach nicht drauf sitzen
kann also ich weiß nicht über diese
diese situation kennt wenn eure hand
eure finger euch einfach nicht mehr
gehorchen hat man manchmal wenn man
heißes so anstrengende ich ist es so
schwierig diese taste zu drücken sagt
manchmal wenn man draußen war in der
kälte und dann nachdem man lange draußen
war die finger so gefühlt abgestorben
sind geht man rein guckt und will dann
aber seine finger benutzen denkt sich so
ok finger drückt jetzt mal die taste
hier untersatz der finger fick dich
machen uns nicht von ein und verwaltet
die funktion so dauert noch mal erreicht
das heißt wir werfen ein item raciti
drei kics ihren top picks wohl etwas
schönes dabei 12 ok jetzt hab ich zwei
gold trust damit ist auch klar was ich
als nichts wegschmeißen
es ist gerade wirklich ich muss wirklich
meine ganze konzentration aufbringen und
einfach nur mein ganzes gehirn meine
ganze gehirnleistung in meinen kleinen
finger an der linken hand verlagern um
überhaupt diesen komischen steuerung
button drücken zu können
mein kleiner finger sagt mir einfach
genau jetzt in dem moment so [ __ ] you
heute nicht was ich lange genug
ausgenutzt heute einfach nicht so
aber darum haben wir da schon was haben
wir beschlossen haben wir nicht leute
ich will der beste und versenkte eiskalt
in itunes wegzuschmeißen
okay erzählt drei herausnehmen was eine
leichte entscheidung dass ein leicht
entscheidung in dem die mit aber bis
jetzt habe ich jetzt ein bisschen spät
gemacht jetzt teilweise habe ich jetzt
noch nie ganz versteckt wie man's
wegzuschmeißen kurz wird kurze frage am
rande warum sind in dieser runde nur
vier leute die hunde war voll als sich
ein dicker brocken eingezäunt da waren
fünf leute drin
mit mir sind es sechs wir sind ja alle
hin
die letzte game of the game alles klar
die leute verlassen guck mal sie den den
übeltäter hier der der ist es jetzt hier
muss man doppel job machen meist aber so
schön und dann vielleicht noch von hier
oben runter das sollte eigentlich safe
seien ja wohl checkpoint und checkpoint
heißt ein altem wegschmeißen
wisst ihr was wisst ihr was ich bin auf
risiko
soll ich ja komisch ist ob ich was mit
steinen start weg ich hoffe jetzt
einfach mal dass da draußen noch mal
warum finde auf dem weg ansonsten wird
es einen death match in dem ich einfach
sterben werde
deathmatch ein stück einfach so ok drei
teams 123 12 f haben wir alter habe ich
schon jemals jemanden gesehen der so
apfel rich ist wie ich in dieser runde
12 äpfel
jetzt ist es schon schwieriger sprung
leder geht sogar okay wenn wir das
erreicht hast wieder ein item weg jetzt
muss man die fehlern gehen jetzt in die
ferien gehen jetzt viel schöner dann die
leiter und weiter im text
das schaffen wir jetzt ja wie spring
jetzt an die leiter du drückst steuerung
wir schaffen das ok und switches
halte diese sender habe ich früher mal
kräftig gesucht
keiner von euch switch lief damals auf
prosieben glaube ich das war der shit
alter gut drei teams 123 würde ich sagen
wir eine schöne kleine leggins und wer
mit schönen kleinen helm
aber wir haben immer noch keine waffe
und des death match kommt einfach 20
sekunden
wie soll das funktionieren
minute eckball erreicht goldlagers
trauer nicht ok kommen wir da noch nein
wir kommen nicht mal 'ne kiste war okay
jeder da draußen haut sich gerade mit
der flachen hand gegen den kopf mit
vollem anlauf hat auch damit vollkommen
recht aber es gibt kein aber was machen
wir jetzt wir warten einfach ab bis
einer stirbt und versuchen abzustauben
leider bestes deathmatch tk sixteen ohne
witz mann war noch nie so brok einem das
match glaube ich leute kann das
funktionieren kann das funktionieren
sechseinhalb stunden später warum man
warum warum warum
angelo hat nur noch wenig leben wir
müssen jetzt einfach rein drücken können
wir ihn töten
nein oh gott wo ist der fall eingegangen
mutterverein gegangen ich weiß nicht was
es nicht geben müssen vergeben erst mit
der hand mit der hand hütten
ich glaube mit der hand wird es ziemlich
ziemlich schwierig kann das sein
euro oder müssen jetzt abwarten bis eine
antwort klatscht man ja aber ihr die
indianerstämme private sieht ihn
woanders gestorben antwort gestorben
andreas gestorben finger weg von der
kiste da ist nicht nichts spannendes
drin nichts spannendes nein nein
finger weg von der kiste finger nein ich
kann mich auch nicht rausnehmen gott oh
gott ich kann dir hoffentlich rausnehmen
alles da
jetzt müssen wir abwarten bis der
followers einfach stirbt gott das ist
wirklich das brachte das große
deathmatch niemals jemals war ein
deathmatch so brok wie dieses kann man
es schaffen
wir haben halbwegs ordentliche summe
können paar hits wegstecken wenn diese
jetzt boxen gehen wir einfach rein ja
wohl genau jetzt ja wohl nicht fasst
mich leute ich fasse es nicht wir haben
tatsächlich und schwert jetzt mit
millionengewinn jetzt und ohne witz als
ja wohl jetzt muss es geben
ja
ja okay es sind auch ein mitgegeben
können wir hier ja wir können hier ganz
ins land und beginn noch mit
und wir haben die grameen gekillt hatte
noch leben hatte noch am leben
leute wir haben zusätzliche
zurückgeschafft das gibt's nicht das
gibt es nicht das ist es wahr dass broke
the dead weather und wir haben einfach
das den comeback geschafft und wir haben
nicht unrealistische chance jetzt zu
töten klar es ist immer noch schwer weil
er dreieinhalb 56 punkte hat ein mehr
als wir lieber auf sexy genau welche los
punkte wir können stoffe können schaffen
müssen ok nahkampf incoming jawohl wir
sind besser wir sind besser je mehr wir
haben das ding einfach gewonnen wird
gibt es das gibt es dass man ich habe
die arge noch habe ich meinen schein
schotter weggeschmissen was hat nicht
gelitten da sie meinen steinfurter
weggeschmissen habe aber wir haben es
geschafft alter aber so richtig richtig
hart aber wirklich gefallen hat will
mich freuen wenn die daumen nach oben da
las und wie immer challenges in die
kommentare schreibt es wird heute montag
weil ich gar nicht mehr so viel zeit
habe ich bin mega chaos vom training
werde wahrscheinlich nie mehr so viel
schlaf kriegen deswegen wollte mal so in
one take wie gesagt ist auch in ordnung
aber dafür gibt's noch zwei videos ganz
fleißig wieder geschändet und in die
kommentare schreiben
dann freut sich der sinken das war so
weit von mir haut rein leute macht's gut
und